hi welcome everybody and I want to share
it takes about Robert Sapolsky that I
have pirated from web somebody has
written elegantly about him I wouldn't
be able to as a boy in New York City
Robert Sapolsky dreamed of living inside
the African dioramas in the Museum of
Natural History
by the age of 21 he made it to Africa
and joined the troop of baboons although
the life of a naturalist appealed to him
because it was a chance to get the hell
out of Brooklyn
he never really left people behind his
gift for storytelling led the New York
Times to suggest if you cross Jane
Goodall with a brougt
belt comedian she might have written a
book like a primates memoir suppose keys
account of his early years as a field
biologist the uniqueness of Sapolsky his
perspective on the human condition comes
from the ease with which he combines his
insights from the field with his
findings as a neuroscientist what makes
Sapolsky great is that he connects
science with society and human life and
with human nature he tackles the
question of human mind with similar
questions that kept our total Copernicus
and Shakespeare awake in the middle of
the night for more than 30 years
Sapolsky has divided his time between
fieldwork and primates and highly
technical neurological research in his
laboratory at stanford as a result he
can effortlessly move from a discussion
of pecking orders in primates to an
explanation of how neurotransmitters
work during stress and gets laugh during
it Sapolsky regards is this sobering
news with characteristic good humor
finding hope in our own capacity to
prevent some of these problems in the
small steps with which we live our
everyday life the humor and human
he brings two sometimes sobering subject
matter makes Sapolsky a fascinating
speaker as you will witness he he
lectures widely on topics as diverse as
stress and stress-related diseases
baboon's the biology of our
individuality and so on you name it
Sapolsky is a MacArthur Genius fellow a
professor of biology at neurology and
department of biology at Stanford
University and a research associate with
the Institute of primate research at the
National Museum of Kenya in 2008
National Geographic and PBS aired an
hour-long special on stress featuring
Robert Sapolsky and his research on the
subject matter Sapolsky was awarded
Rockefeller University's Lewis Thomas
Prix prize for writing about science his
articles have appeared in publications
such as Discover and The New Yorker and
he writes a biweekly column for The Wall
Street Journal entitled mind and matter
in addition to a primates memoir suppose
he has written for other books including
the trouble with testosterone why zebras
don't get ulcers and monkey love and
other essays on our lives as animals and
his most recent book behaved the biology
of humans at our best and worst
to quote my colleague David Eagleman a
neuroscientist at Stanford University
his latest book as wide as it is deep it
is colorful electrifying and moving
Sapolsky leverages his deep expertise to
ask the most fundamental questions about
being human from acts of hate to acts of
love from our compulsion to dehumanize
and to rehumanize we are delighted that
Robert has accepted our invitation to
talk about the biology of humans at our
best and worst this lecture is kindly
and generously sponsored by a gift from
Christina and Hameed macadam to iranian
studies
program at Stanford and by the
laboratory of cognitive and behavioral
neuroscience and cognitive neuroscience
interest group I welcome everybody and
joining me to welcome Robert Sapolsky
thank you
well singer Lee strange to have so many
people in an audience not wondering if
this is gonna be on the final so thank
you all for being here now let me start
off a little bit unorthodox Lee here let
me start off with a fantasy I first had
as a kid
and it was a fantasy of the day I
captured Hitler I over powered his elite
guard I burst into his secret bunker I
wrestled his Luger out of his hand
we grappled with each other I pinned him
down got handcuffs on him and was able
to say Adolf Hitler I arrest you for
crimes against humanity and at that
point the the Medal of Honor version of
this fantasy would get a little bit
harder to maintain and viscera would
start to creep in what would I do if I
had had Hitler and if I let myself go
there it wasn't actually hard to think
about it
sever his spine at the neck take out his
eyes puncture his eardrum cut out his
tongue inject him with some sort of
cancer that would just postulate on
every cell in his body I had this
fantasy at various points when I was a
kid and sometimes I still do and when I
do my heart beats faster and my
breathing gets faster all this planning
for the most evil human and all of
history the sole most deserving of
damage of punishment except I have a
problem with that which is I don't
believe in Souls and I don't believe in
evil and I don't believe in punishment
I think wicked only belongs in the title
of the musical but at the same time at
the same time there's all sorts of
people I would like to see dead but I'm
against the death penalty but there's
lots of violence schlocky movies I like
going to but I'm for very strict gun
control but then there was a time I went
to that laser quest place
such a good time hiding in a corner
shooting at people in other words I'm
your basic confused human when it comes
to feelings about violence now I don't
need to get up on the soapbox here about
the problems we've got with violence as
a species we've used shower heads to
deliver poison gas letters with anthrax
passenger planes as weapons rape as a
military strategy we are a miserably
violent species but there's two problems
with that at least the first one is we
don't hate violence we hate the wrong
kind of violence when it's the right
kind we get all excited we leap in to
see it we hand out medals we
disproportionately vote for meet with
the people who are best at that when
it's the right kind of violence we love
it the other complication is when it
comes to being a violent species
we're just extraordinarily weird I mean
some of the time we're just like any old
ship we take some big old heavy rock and
cuddle somebody's brain and but some of
the time we can be wildly violent to
mean nothing more metabolically taxing
than pulling a trigger or signing an
order or looking the other way or
damning with faint praise or being
passive-aggressive we do the theory odd
thing when it comes to violence let me
give you one of the single strangest
examples of violence I've ever heard of
and this is one having to do with
Indonesia in the 1960s
mid 60s there was a coup that overthrew
the government there instituted a
right-wing military dictatorship for the
next thirty years and in the year
afterward approximately half a million
Indonesians were killed by right-wing
death squads if you were an intellectual
if you were a leftist if you were of any
of the ethnic minorities that were
out-groups their savagery death squads
would come to a village systematically
kill every single person in that village
so decades later the writer VS Naipaul
was traveling through Indonesia and he
would hear stories about what happened
at the time and he kept hearing this
crazy story which was sometimes these
death squads would show up at a village
to kill everyone and they would bring
along a traditional Indonesian gamelan
orchestra nuts one day he runs across
one of these old grizzled veterans of
one of these death squads he's talking
to the guy he's proud to sort of brag
about all the villagers and civilians he
killed saving the nation and lipo
finally said you know this crazy thing
about how sometimes you people would
bring like gamelan orchestras to these
massacres is that and the guy said oh
yes yes whenever we could we would bring
an orchestra along an eyeball said why
would you do that and in one sentence
the guy looked puzzled and just
encapsulated everything that's weird
about our violence he said to make it
more beautiful of course there is no
other primate on earth that could make
sense of our violence when we're
bringing along orchestras to make it
more beautiful now the single most
complicated about thing about us being
this miserably violent species is at the
same time we're the most altruistic most
cooperative most empathic species on
earth and we're getting better at it
consider every single thing up here was
invented in the last century all these
ways in which we are extending sort of
an umbrella of empathy and protection
and all sorts of unlikely directions
where this phenomenally violent species
were this phenomenally cooperative
empathic one how do we begin to possibly
make sense of the biology of us at our
best and worst now one of the things is
clear about it it is utterly boring if
all you want to figure out try to make
sense of us as a primate amid all the
others where are these extremes of our
behavior come from it's totally boring
if all you want to do is understand the
motoric aspects of the behavior your
brain tells your spine tells your
muscles to do something and hurray
you've behaved what's much more
interesting is to understand the meaning
of the behavior because in one setting
you pull a trigger and it's an appalling
act and another setting you heroically
suicidally pull fire onto yourself and
it's an awe-inspiring act in one setting
you put your hand on someone else's and
it's a moment of deep compassion and
another the exact same motoric behavior
and it's
first step of a deep betrayal the
challenge with us and understanding our
behavior is understanding the context of
it and that's real challenging now one
of the things that is absolutely clear
with that is you were gonna get nowhere
and understanding these features of our
behavior if you decide here is the part
of the brain that explains everything
that's going on or here is the hormone
or the gene or the childhood experience
or the anything here's the whatever that
explains everything instead if we're
going to make any sense of these complex
context dependent behaviors of ours we
have to look at many layers so one of
these behaviors happens it's wonderful
it's appalling it's ambiguously
somewhere in between and we ask the
biological question why did that
behavior just happen and when we do that
we're actually asking a whole array of
questions what went on one second before
and that person's nervous system that
instructed those muscles to do that good
bad in between behavior but we're also
asking what was going on seconds to
minutes before in the sensory world that
triggered those neurons and we're also
asking what was going on with hormone
levels hours two days before that made
that organism more or less sensitive to
certain sensory stimuli that caused and
then back to adolescence and childhood
in fetal life and back to when you were
just a fertilized egg and then back to
what sort of culture your ancestors came
up with and what sort of echo systems
and what evolutionary forces sculpted
all of that if you want to get a sense
you're going to have to ask that
question on all these levels ok so
beginning with that one of our behaviors
has happened and we do our first version
of saying why did that occur what went
on of the brain one second before that
context dependent trigger was pulled
that context dependent hand was touched
why did that occur so if we're going to
start off with the worst of our human
behaviors right off the bat we start off
with a part of the brain the amygdala
the amygdala is about aggression it's
about violence stimulate the amygdala
and a rat
monkey a human you get unprovoked
aggression destroy the amygdala you're
unable to elicit aggression anymore the
amygdala is about aggression if you take
an amygdala gist though and you sit him
down and you say what's the amygdala
about aggression is not the first word
they're gonna mention the first one is
fear the amygdala is about fear
it's about phobias and eight fears even
more importantly it's about where you
learn to be afraid of things fear
conditioning and such in other words you
cannot understand the neurobiology of
violence without understanding the
neurobiology of fear and in a world in
which no amygdaloid neuron need be
afraid there'd be a lot more of us
sleeping between lions and labs now the
whole thing about the amygdala and
processing fear is it does something
very interesting with sensory
information ok so you see something
officially scary oh no there's a
rattlesnake how does this get processed
in your brain the most straightforward
thing is visual information goes to the
sensory Waystation the thalamus and then
it sends it on to the visual cortex and
then begins a whole science fair project
the first layer of your visual cortex
breaks this down into pixels and then as
it hands it to the second layer which
turns it into lines and then the next
layer moving lines and layer after that
and layer and going through your memory
and like your golden book of snakes and
finally somewhere up in your cortex it
says oh my that's a rattlesnake perhaps
we should let those fellows down in the
amygdala know about it this is glacial
from the standpoint of the nervous
system turns out in addition to that
pathway there's a shortcut that very
first volley of visual information
getting into that thalamus has a
shortcut that gets to the amygdala in
other words the amygdala knows that
you're looking at a rattlesnake while
your visual cortex is still fussing
around with the instruction manuals and
later - in other words your amygdala can
know what that is before you're even
consciously aware of it
and this is all in the course of
hundreds of milliseconds tenths of a
second okay that's great that's very
good if your amygdala already knows
you're looking at a rattlesnake that's
terrific but there's a downside which is
there's a reason why you've got your
visual cortex doing all that complexity
it's to make sure you're accurate about
what you decide you're looking at and
that amygdala getting that lightning
fast reflexive information is all set up
to make a mistake and before you know it
you think the guy who just happens to
look in a certain way the guys holding
the cell phone is actually holding a
handgun instead and you pull that
trigger in other words the amygdala gets
all this privileged information at the
intersection of aggression and fear this
privileged information
but catastrophic Lee at times the
information is not terribly accurate
next part of the brain area called the
insula insular cortex take any mammal
out there and give it some rotten
disgusting spoiled food to bite into and
as soon as it does the insula activates
and that triggers all these reflexes
animal gags it spits it out as stomach
heaves it throws up whatever the insula
keeps you from poisoning yourself with
toxic food that's great so you get
someone like college freshmen to
volunteers for this and goes into a
brain scanner and bites into some rancid
fetid food and same deal insula
activates but now instead don't have the
person eat something disgusting have
them just think about it think about
those little legs pushing against your
lips as you try to and you're gonna
activate your insular cortex ah in most
mammals it does gustatory disgust and us
it also does thoughts about gustatory
disgust but then something even more
interesting well don't give the person
something disgusting to eat don't make
them think about something disgusting
eat make them think about something else
that's disgusting make them think about
something that is morally disgusting and
the insula activates in humans this part
of the brain also mediates moral disgust
and presumably forty fifty thousand
years ago when we came
with the notion of norm violations that
could be so extreme that it winds up
being appalling they had a meeting they
said we can't invent a new part of the
brain watch that insula does disgusting
foods disgusting behavior I don't know
sounds similar expand it in there give
me some duct tape and now suddenly your
insulin also does moral disgust that's
why if something is sufficiently morally
disgusting we feel sick to our stomachs
it leaves a bad taste in our mouth we
feel queasy now this is great because
this certainly gives a lot of visceral
force to things that we find to be
morally appalling but there's a problem
with us which of course is that one
person's morally disgusting behavior is
somebody else's perfectly normal loving
lifestyle
in other words moral disgust is a moving
target and the trouble with the visceral
force of moral disgust is it just begs
you to use it as a litmus test to decide
how do I figure out what's right and
wrong in the world well if it seems so
different from what I normally do that
I'm feeling a little queasy it's wrong
wrong and wrong and this wisdom of
repugnance is a way of making some very
bad moral choices okay so what we see
with the insula most mammals it's about
sensory disgust in us instead it's about
moral discussed which is intensely
context dependent and what we see there
is the insula is central to us deciding
that just because something is so
different that it's hitting all sorts of
visceral alarms that there's something
that's got to be where I can't tell you
why but when they do that it's just
simply wrong and the first place in the
brain the insula screams that news -
next is the amygdala meanwhile another
part of the brain in reference to all of
this frontal cortex frontal cortex the
most interesting part of the brain it's
most recently evolved we've got more of
it proportionately than any other
species
what is the frontal cortex - it makes
you do the harder thing when it's the
right thing to do
gratification postponement long-term
planning impulse control emotional
regulation the frontal cortex is the
part of the brain that says hold on hold
on hold on
are going to be happy you did it it does
all of those harder things when it's the
right thing now of course the picture is
frontal cortex and amygdala have a lot
to do with each other which is the
frontal cortex spends a whole lot of
time sending inhibitory projections down
into the amygdala saying I wouldn't do
that if I were you I know it seems
really tempting right now you're gonna
regret it I wouldn't do that I wouldn't
racing to the amygdala before that
shortcut gets the amygdala to do
something stupid and impulsive there and
the picture you get is basically all of
the frontal cortical amygdaloid
interactions are top-down the only thing
the frontal cortex has to do with the
amygdala is like showing up and
preaching Christian Temperance and
things like that and other than that
it's this very one directional
relationship in actuality it's two
directional because we see versions of
this all the time this is every single
time in some moment of arousal a fear of
stress of who knows what you make some
decision that seems brilliant at the
timing you spend the rest of your life
regretting it ah it's not just one
direction bottom-up explains an awful
lot of when we decide something is the
right thing to do in one given moment
and may not think that way one and a
half seconds from now
and what this speaks to is the whole
notion of doing the harder thing when
it's the right thing to do the right
thing is once again very context
dependent I mean think about this all of
these are circumstances where you need
self-control to pull things off I mean
look at this you are in a circumstance
where you're being tempted to lie about
something for personal gain and you're
trying to avoid the temptation to do
that your frontal cortex is playing a
central role if you're going to resist
that temptation but the second you
decide you are going to lie your frontal
cortex is essential for you doing a good
job at it remember make eye contact now
and then and don't let my voice crack in
control if you've got a part of the
brain that's both central to resisting
the temptation to lie but once you
decide to lie doing a good job at it
this is a very very complex brain region
here okay so the frontal cortex makes
you do the harder thing when it's the
right thing to do that's very much a
contact
dependent behavior and the main thing is
the frontal cortex is not this gleaming
cerebral bit of like cognition it's just
marinating all the visceral yuck
coming up from underneath it's a very
bi-directional relationship few more
brain regions one more the dopamine
system dopamine a neurotransmitter one
use of it in the brain in the mesolimbic
dopamine system dopamine has to do with
pleasure with reward cocaine works on
the dopamine system give a rat a monkey
a human a reward from out of nowhere the
don't the dopamine system activates
dopamine is about reward but then people
figure it out it's actually about
something much more interesting than
that now set up this paradigm a little
light comes on of the room as a signal
and that means if you go to this lever
and you press it ten times you get a
reward signal saying it's the start of
one of those sessions go do the work you
get a reward
once that rat monkey human learns this
relationship what happens now when does
dopamine rise does arise when you get
the reward absolutely not it rises when
the signal comes on that's the yeah I
know how this works this is gonna be
great I'm all over this lever pressing
stuff this is terrific the dopamine is
about reward but even more so it's about
the anticipation of reward and
remarkably if you block the rise and
dopamine there the organism doesn't
press the lever it's about the goal
directed the behavior it's about the
pursuit of reward rather than about
reward itself now what I just showed you
in these circumstances was you press the
lever you got the reward press the lever
reward a hundred percent of the time
what if now you switch things switch
things to you press the lever and only
50% of the time you get a reward what
happens to dopamine now it goes through
the roof like crazy because what have
you done you've just inserted a critical
word into this neuro chemistry the word
maybe and nothing fuels dopamine like
maybe being right on that fulcrum of
today's my lucky day but I'm such a
screw-up but no today is my lucky socks
but I'm a total dork and just going back
and forth on that and that may be
nothing cranks out reward related
behavior motivated behavior like
intermittent reinforcement and maybe put
in there and this is what the
neuroscientist she built Las Vegas no
inside out the power of this
okay so what's dopamine doing here it's
about reward even more so anticipation
reward even more so goal directed
behavior in order to get that reward and
what we see is maybe putting uncertainty
into the system is crazy ly crazily
stimulating and if you want to take an
organism and get it pumping out dopamine
like crazy all you need to do is put it
in the circumstance when they are
punishing an individual that has done a
norm violation we will come back to that
okay couple more brain regions fusiform
cortex it's a primate specialty
recognizes faces and Terrier cingulate
it has to do with empathy feeling
somebody else's pain but they both come
with fine print flash up faces fusiform
cortex is activating flash up the face
of someone from a different race and on
the average the fusiform doesn't
activate as much the face doesn't
register as much you don't remember it
as accurately show somebody a film clip
of a hand being poked with a needle and
the anterior cingulate activates an
empathy if the hand skin colour is
different from your own
it doesn't activate as much whose face
whose pain all of these as qualifiers
okay so this begins to give us just a
sense
tip of the iceberg of what's going on of
that one second before that behavior
occurs but no brain is an island and
when we look at one of these behaviors
good/bad in between we're asking why did
this behavior occur we're now also
asking something about seconds to
minutes before what sensory information
had an effect on the amygdala the
frontal cortex etc where do these whine
to being relevant and what I put in this
slide here is summarizing
gazillion different studies showing
sensory information is altering our
behavior in ways where we have in a clue
this is happening for example put up a
pair of eyes on a bus stop and people
literally have a pair of eyes like that
flash up subliminally for less than a
second while somebody is playing in an
online game and they cheat less they
become more generous you're being
watched give somebody some horrible cod
liver oil to drink and just tastes
Harlin and for minutes afterward people
will be more punitive about norm
violations they're confusing a bad taste
with a bad act or how about this one put
somebody in a room and give them a
questionnaire to fill out about their
political views and if there's smelly
garbage in the room people become more
socially conservative doesn't do a thing
to your economic views your geopolitical
views you feel the same way about our
trade deficit with Swaziland that you
did this morning but them and their
different lifestyles suddenly begin to
seem them and disgusting and wrong wrong
wrong
just because visceral disgust alarms are
going off because there's smelly garbage
in the room how about this one sit
somebody in a chair either a hard wooden
one or a nice plush sofa like that and
give them job applications from like
resumes of suppose of applicants and
they evaluate them afterward if you sit
in a hard wooden chair on the average
you were more likely to assess
applicants as having a rigid inflexible
personality you are more likely to think
they're hard asses because of the chair
you're sitting in or how about this one
up on the right there this was a study
in PNAS very prestigious journal a few
years ago looking in a country all of
the parole board hearings in that
country over the course of a year 5,000
hearings looking at who was sent back to
jail versus who was given parole looking
at all sorts of variables and out of it
popped an extraordinary finding the
single biggest predictor of whether or
not a prisoner got parole or not while
how many hours it had been since the
judge had had a meal if you went before
a judge right after a meal 60% chance of
being paroled four hours later down to
zero just this line along comes lunch
down again a little snack afterward down
again it goes and what is extraordinary
about this is two things first we
understand the biology of this blood
glucose levels have something to do with
whether your neurons can work really
hard and what counts is working really
hard near frontal cortex viewing the
world from someone else's perspective
trying to think about their mitigating
circumstances the frontal cortex takes a
lot of energy to do the harder thing and
what's even more striking is if you took
any of those judges two seconds after
they made that decision and you said
okay so why'd you send this guy back to
jail but this guy walk they're not gonna
say oh because of my blood glucose no
they're you get a site like freshman
philosophy class or something and all
the while this is the interceptive the
internal sensory information that was
shaping that decision finally top left
the most depressing finding in this
whole field is you take people put them
in a brain scanner and you're flashing
up faces like tenth of a second barely
noticeable high-speed and for your
average person you flash up the face of
someone of a different race and the
amygdala activates oh crap hardwired on
a tenth of a second to have a racist
response like that is this inevitable
are we like is this hopeless for us
there again now do the experiment a
little bit differently I recently found
out that apparently San Francisco has a
baseball team so and that supposedly
they have this rival that they get very
worked up about and now you're flashing
up the faces and each face is wearing a
baseball cap and if you get the right
San Francisco baseball fanatic if it's
the home team you get one response if
it's the rival the amygdala activates
and you
not processing skin-color oh my god the
innate nature of human racism my ass all
it takes is this cultural thing we
invented one or two centuries ago and
which one counts as an us or them and
baseball loyalties overrides that and
you've recategorize people within
milliseconds there okay so in terms of
the sensory stuff we are constantly
being buffeted constantly being
influenced by sensory information like
this and half the time we haven't a clue
it's there or it can imagine it's
relevant to our and judicial decisions
okay so now pushing further back our
behaviors occurred what's relevant in
the hours two days before what two
hormones have to do with what goes on
here now if we're talking about humans
that they're worse - right off the bat
we know which hormone to roundup
testosterone so what's the deal with
testosterone why are males of every
species in every cultures such a pain in
the rear on this planet here it's
because testosterone makes you
aggressive testosteron doesn't make you
aggressive here's what it actually does
take five male rhesus monkeys put them
in a group let them form a dominance
hierarchy Aida feeds be three times B
and ever defeats a this is hierarchy now
take C and inject C with testosterone
give C like so much testosterone like
every amygdaloid neuron is growing
antlers and that God just enormous so
now to see get involved in more fights
absolutely is this the pattern that
occurs now is see suddenly challenging a
and B and rising in the hot absolutely
not
C never does a thing with a and B what
happens instead is C becomes a total
nightmare at D and E testosterone does
not invent aggression testosterone
exaggerated spree existing social
patterns of aggression and it turns out
it does something even more subtle than
that and this is people beginning to
realize what testosterone really does is
when your status is being challenged
testosterone makes you do whatever you
need to do to maintain
now if you're a baboon and somebody's
challenging your status the way you
maintain it is you have a fight with
them it's anonymous but with your human
things can more complicated and for
example you can have an economic game
where people get status by making
generous offers and give people
testosterone and they become more
generous in the game in other words if
you shot up a whole bunch of Buddhist
monks with testosterone they would run
amok doing random acts of kindness all
over the place the trouble isn't that
testosterone makes us aggressive the
trouble is that we reward aggression
with status so readily meanwhile if
we're talking about sort of the good
side of our behavior the hormone that
immediately comes to mind is oxytocin
oxytocin is officially the grooviest
hormone of the world
oxytocin promotes mother-infant bonding
pair bonding trust expressivity
cooperation generosity give fruitflies
oxytocin they become better listeners
all sorts of stuff like that
oxytocin promotes pro-social behavior
oxytocin doesn't no such thing once you
look more closely
one example of this this was worked on a
few years ago in the Netherlands and
volunteers there were given this classic
problem in philosophy the runaway
trolley problem a trolley is broken
loose from its brakes is hurtling down
the tracks it's going to kill five
people is it okay to push one person
onto the track who will be killed what
will slow down the trolley can you
sacrifice one to save five basic
utilitarian stuff philosophers have been
dealing with the runaway trolley problem
since I'm a no Aristotle took his first
trolley it turns out how you frame it
matters is it okay to push your person
versus is okay to pull a lever that
dumps the person you get totally
different answers from people okay so
they give these volunteers the runaway
trolley problem and the key thing in
this study was they gave a name to the
person you were pushing on the track
either it was somebody with a classic
good-old-boy dutch name like dirt
or Peter or something or it was one of
two groups that consistently invoke
negative connotations in Holland people
from Germany oh that's right World War
two or people with Muslim names so now
you got a choice so are you gonna push
Dirk onto the tracks what about Wolfgang
what about Mahmud and it turns out you
give people oxytocin and they're far
more likely to spare Dirk and they fall
over themselves to throw Otto and
Wolfgang and Mahmud under the tracks
there oxytocin doesn't make us more
pro-social and makes us more pro-social
to people who feel like in us if it's a
them and makes us crappier and more
xenophobic to them so in both cases
we've got hormones affecting our brains
or sensory systems but far more subtly
than you might think and the problem
with testosterone is that we reward
status to aggression so readily not a
testosterone causes it and the thing
about oxytocin is it doesn't make us
more pro-social it exaggerated s' this
divide between us as and vamps okay so
now pushing further back with our
behavior
what about weeks to months before and
the critical thing in this realm is it
turns out over that time span the brain
changes the brain changes dramatically
neurons form new connections they
shrivel up old ones brain regions get
bigger they get smaller it's the biggest
revolution top left it turns out the
adult brain and one region makes new
neurons completely new neurons under
certain sir
the brain shows neuroplasticity
incredibly exciting stuff with all sorts
of fine print there first off amid
having the brain having this enormous
potential Thunder a plasticity there's
limits no amount of neuroplasticity is
going to make any of us into a yo-yo ma
or no amount of neuroplasticity
currently is good to do much for you if
your spinal cord has been severed
moreover more importantly
neuroplasticity is a value-free
phenomenon because sometimes
neuroplasticity can make you much better
at being a saint and sometimes it can
make you better at
ethnically cleansing villages it's not
an intrinsic good or bad now pushing
further back how about back to your
adolescence and it turns out everything
about adolescent behavior is explained
by two facts first off your dopamine
system is going full blast by the time
you're about 11 or 12 second your
frontal cortex is half-baked when you're
a teenager frontal cortex is not fully
online amazingly enough until you're
about 25 years old in other words this
is why juveniles behave in juvenile ways
impulse issues and sensation seeking and
novelty seeking and peer effects and
conformity and all of that and what's
this for our purposes
what is this relevant to in terms of
that second where you eye there are
aren't going to pull that trigger what
this tells you is late adolescence early
adulthood is when environment is having
its bigger this affects what kind of
frontal cortex you're gonna have it as
an adult and that has a critical
implication
okay so adolescence is all about
dopaminergic maturity frontal cortical
immaturity with the critical thing there
is if the frontal cortex is the last
part of the brain to come online by
definition it's the part of the brain
least shaped by your genes and most
shaped by your experience and
environment and it's gotta be that way
because what's the difficult subtle
doing the right thing when it's the
harder thing to do kind of stuff that
takes forever to master cultural
relativity context-dependent rules thou
shalt not kill but it's really good to
kill them and you don't lie but this is
a good time to lie and hypocrisy and
self-serving sty and that no genes are
gonna code for that your frontal cortex
needs 25 years to master stuff like that
hurdling further back how about now back
to childhood what does that have to do
with the adult brain an adult decision
you will make in that one second there
as to what to do all of it is built
around something that is totally obvious
which is childhood matters and different
types of childhoods produce different
types of adults
and the central question of that field
is how do different types of childhoods
produce different frontal cortexes and
different amygdalas and different what
are the mechanisms by which early
experience has a lifelong organizational
effect on brain and behavior
now what this brings us into is this
insanely trendy field called epigenetics
genetics your genes your DNA sequences
experience doesn't change those what
epigenetic experience changes though is
the regulation of those genes when they
are activated okay what would this look
like amazingly enough it turns out in
the world of rat mother's some rat
mothers are better at mothering than
other rat mothers okay what counts as a
good rat mother she picks up her pup a
lot she licks up a lot she grooms that a
lot this is a wonderful rat mother and
it turns out if you are subject as a rat
pup to such attentive rat mothering that
causes an epigenetic change in a part of
your brain and as a result as an adult
you secrete lower levels of stress
hormones into your bloodstream great
book with an interesting implication so
because you were groomed and licked a
lot as an infant your brain
epigenetically shifted and now as an
adult you have nice low levels of stress
hormones when you are a mother because
of those low levels
you're gonna lick and groom your kids
more and thus this trait is going to be
passed on to the next generation
not through genes but through
environmental experience dependent
changes in regulation of genes and the
same thing works prenatally you're a rat
fetus and you're being exposed to tons
of stress hormones why because your mom
is stressed and secreting a lot into her
circulation which gets into your
circulation we get into your brain and
causes epigenetic changes such that as
an adult your amygdala is going to be
bigger and it's going to be more
reactive to threat and you're gonna have
higher stress hormone levels
and as a result when you're pregnant
your fetus is going to be exposed to
more of these stress hormones in other
words we have early environment shaping
all sorts of aspects of how the brain
and the endocrine systems are put
together and most importantly thanks to
these epigenetic changes starting during
fetal life environment does not begin at
birth these changes can be long lasting
lifelong even multi-generational ok but
now one step further back forget when
you were a kid or a fetus how about back
when you were nothing more than just a
fertilized egg
what do genes have to do with it and
there's no subject in this whole lecture
that's more contentious than the role of
a genes and behavior and this is because
we live in an hysterically giddy period
about genetics these days we've
sequenced the human genome they can do
it in the evening now if you go into the
right like you know McDonald's or
whatever the genome with a code of codes
the Holy Grail the notion that your
genes shape everything that happens in
you and the thing is your genes have no
idea what they're doing saying that a
gene knows for example when it is going
to regulate cell biology saying that a
gene knows what it's doing is like
saying that a cake recipe knows when
you're going to make the cake or decides
when you were going to make the cake
genes don't regulate themselves what
regulates genes environment does
environment can be very local the local
environment in a Cell that's running out
of energy and that turns on a gene which
makes more of a glucose transporter
protein and the cell takes up more
energy change an environment alters gene
activity and you fix the problem or
environment could be on the level of the
whole body high levels of testosterone
and as a result in this muscle cell
certain genes are turned on and the
muscle cell grows bigger you put on
muscle mass or environment could be
environment in the conventional sense
you've just given birth you smell your
baby
and as a result genes are turned on and
you start making oxytocin Oh
jeans run all of life there this that's
you smell your baby's tush and as a
result you change gene transcription
genes don't really know what they're
doing
genes are being regulated by environment
and the critical thing is different
environments regulate the same genes in
different ways do not dream of writing
down any of this but what we have here
are a whole bunch of genes that have
effects on behavior only in certain
environments for our purpose the most
interesting one in red they're a gene
called Mao health of monoamine oxidase
alpha it's got something to do with this
inner transmitter serotonin all that
matters is it comes in two different
flavors and by all logic one of those
flavors should set you up for higher
levels of aggression and a huge huge
study was done some years ago following
17,000 kids for decades and the answer
comes back if you've got the wrong
version of this gene you are indeed as a
young adult more likely to already have
a history of antisocial violent behavior
if and only if you were abused as a
child if you weren't raised with abuse 0
effect whatsoever in other words it's
not what the gene is it's not what the
environment is but the interaction
between the two in other words genes
decide nothing instead they're being
regulated by environments efficiently so
that it never makes sense to ask what a
gene does or an environment does only in
a particular context of interaction ok
that's great so that tells us something
about why jeans and a penguin may work
differently in the middle of the Sahara
or something but yeah you're not gonna
see penguins there but you're going to
see humans there and in Antarctica and
in tundra and in rainforests and
polygamous society is a monogamous and
capitalist and socialist there's no
species on earth that lives in more
different environments thus by
definition there's no species on earth
that is freer of genetic determination
than we are ok so now we're back to
fertilized egg that's the end of us but
amazingly we got to push further back
because to make sense of all of this we
after I asked what were your ancestors
doing what sort of cultures were they
inventing because that's gonna influence
how you are going to turn into that
adult that you are
what sort of cultures did they invent
turns out to be very sensitive to what
sort of ecosystems they lived in for
example across the world desert dwellers
are statistically more likely than
chance to invent monotheistic religions
rain forest dwellers invent polytheistic
ones and all sorts of baggage that goes
along with that another pattern when you
look at humans living in small
hunter-gatherer bands the religions they
invent involve almost all the time
involved gods who could care less what
humans are doing it's not until humans
are living in sufficiently high density
that you're interacting with strangers
that you interact anonymously then
humans start inventing what are called
moralizing gods gods who were watching
us and gods who were judging us and gods
who are the pair of eyes up there on the
bus stop there
when we're getting complex enough that
we can't do it ourselves
or another critical status ting ssin has
to do with traditional ways of making a
livelihood the original world people are
either top left hunter-gatherers top
right agriculturalists or
horticulturalist or in the center
pastoralists pastoralists people
wandering the grasslands or the deserts
with their herds of camels and cows and
goats and all of that and there's a
particular vulnerability if you're a
pastoralist
if you're a rainforest hunter-gatherer
bad people cannot come at night and
steal your rainforest if you're an
agriculturist they can't come at night
and steal twenty acres if you're maize
but if you're a pastoralist people could
come a night and steal your herds rustle
your herds there and everywhere around
the world pastoralists come up with
cultures of honor built around violent
retribution warrior classes honor
killings vendetta's that stretch for
centuries and what is most remarkable is
with
minutes of birth if you were a child in
a culture of honor your mother is
speaking to you at a higher volume and
holding you for a shorter length of time
than if you were a child in one of these
other cultures if you were born into a
collectivist culture on the average your
mother is nursing you for longer lengths
of time in your first week of life than
if you were born in an individualist
culture in other words within minutes of
birth everything we've already seen is
now being shaped by what your ancestors
were doing for a living
centuries before in other words
ecosystems shaped cultures shape brains
shape behaviors and some of these
differences are manifest within minutes
of birth in other words brains and
bodies and behaviors and cultures and
jeans all co-evolve
finally if we're gotten this far back
and we're talking about things like
genes by definition we're talking about
evolution what does the evolution of
behavior have to do with any of this and
modern thinking about the evolution
behavior is long ago trash the notion
that we behave for the good of the
species or behave in order to survive we
behave in order to pass on copies of
genes contemporary thinking about the
evolution of behavior is built around
three building blocks first one
individual selection what organisms do
is try to leave as many copies of their
genes in the next generation as possible
maximizing reproductive success The
Selfish Gene concept and this explains a
ton of human behavior for example
remarkably 16 percent of Earth's humans
are direct descendants of djenka scon
the most reproductively successful human
of all time all sorts of powerful humans
act to maximize the reproductive success
next building block yes some of the time
you pass on as many copies of genes as
you can but some of the time an even
better way of doing it is helping your
relatives pass on copies and genes kin
selection and humans have invented a
version of kin selection that makes
other primates shrivel up with envy we
can bequeath our in the
real wealth to our relatives there's
inheritance we have a way of magnifying
differences through generations that way
we do kin selection like nobody else out
there final building block individual
selection or helping relatives or
sometimes their selection for
cooperating with utter strangers being
cooperative altruistic with them as long
as they do it back reciprocal
relationships of cooperation and we
obviously do that on a level like no
other species out there forget
scratching your back and you scratch
mine we've invented barter and economic
system all of that in other words the
building blocks of modern evolutionary
thinking explain a ton about human
behavior until you look more closely
individual selection and then we have
religious sects that are celibate that
choose to go extinct like the shakers
who don't pass on copies of your genes
behaving only for the good of close
relatives and then we have blended
families with children adopted from all
over the planet or reciprocal altruism
we will cooperate with strangers if they
cooperate back think of this this is a
behavior we do which chimps could not
possibly make any sense of you're in a
foreign country you're going to the
airport you're about to leave there you
are never going to set foot in that
country again no person you see there
you will ever set flies on again and as
you walk into the terminal you pause for
a second and hold the door open for
someone
everything about the evolution of
reciprocity and cooperation says there's
no way that could ever become
commonplace and that defines us in other
words evolution of behavior built around
those three principles they explain a
ton about social behavior lots of other
species and they explain a ton about us
until you look more closely ok so what
have we gotten to now we've now
officially seen one of our behaviors
occur and if you want to understand if
that behaviors you've got to incorporate
everything from one millisecond before
to millions of years of selection and
evolutionary pressure in other words one
can officially conclude at this point
it's called
located oh great I had to sit through 50
minutes of this to get to that point
it's complicated let's try to make that
conclusion a little bit more useful it's
complicated so be real careful and real
cautious and real sure you really
understand what's going on if you decide
you understand why some behaviors
happens especially if it's a behavior
that you're judging harshly now for my
purposes the single most important thing
about all of this is all of these realms
of factoids I've been downloading here
all of them have one thing in common
they change they can change over time
they change in response to experience
they change in the most fundamental ways
over long periods over short periods
ecosystems change this is a rock carving
of a hippo which was carved 3000 years
ago in the middle of the Sahara when the
Sahara was lush grassland ecosystems
change cultures change in the 18th
century the most terrifying people in
Europe were the Swedes they spent the
whole century rampaging through Europe
and then something happened something
changed and this is what the Swedish
military does now instead they haven't
had a war in more than a century
cultures change cultures change
dramatically
most importantly brains change new
connections lose old ones expansion
contractions brains change behaviors
change people change
sometimes astounding magnitudes of
change occur they could take decades
this man John Newton was a British
theologian who in his old age played a
central role in the abolition of slavery
in the British Empire in the beginning
of the 1800s and amazingly enough as a
young man and John Newton made a living
as the captain of a slave ship and after
he retired from the sea he spent decades
investing in the slave trade and growing
wealthy from it until one day something
changed something changed celebrated
into him that he wrote that his maid
famous to him Amazing Grace another
version of change that can happen over
decades on the left is a man named Zen
Jia Bay on the morning of December 6
1941 about to lead one of the squadrons
of bombers Japanese bombers that
attacked Pearl Harbor he was one of the
lead pilots in it and on the right is
Zhen Jia Bay to the day fifty years
later where as an old man he came to
Pearl Harbor where there is a ceremony
happening for the elderly survivors of
the attack and in broken English he went
up to those men and he apologized to
them for what he had done so change can
occur on that level sometimes change can
occur over the course of hours today's
one of the most remarkable events in
World War one was the Christmas truce of
1914 the first Christmas the first
December various powers that be decreed
that there would be a three-hour truce
along the trenches in France three hours
in the afternoon before Christmas Eve so
that soldiers from both sides had come
out retrieve their dead from no-man's
land so the fighting stopped and people
came out and retrieved their dead and
then they started helping soldiers from
the other side carry their dead back and
then they started helping each other dig
graves in the frozen ground and then
they started having ceremonies and
funerals together and praying over each
other's dead and before it was over with
they were sharing Christmas dinner and
praying together and exchanging presents
and singing and by the next day up and
down the trench lines of France German
and British soldiers were playing soccer
together and weren't keeping score and
they exchanged weapons and they
exchanged addresses so that they could
visit each other after the war was over
with and they made vows with each other
to shoot over each other's heads so they
wouldn't hurt each other and it took the
officers arriving two to three days into
this and threatening to shoot these men
to get them to go back to trying to kill
each other and the main point there is
all of that acculturation and all of
that millet rating millet
training and all of that propaganda
evaporated in the course of hours as to
who counted as an us and who was the
them us is us in the trenches all of us
in the damn trenches and them as any
officer in the back lines who would have
his die for their power and that just
happened over the course of hours and
sometimes change can occur in minutes
one of the things that galvanized the
anti-war movement during the Vietnam War
in the United States more than anything
was the me Lai massacre a brigade of
American soldiers went into the village
of nilai undefended no weapons made up
of elderly people and children went in
there and killed 350 to 500 civilians
mutilated bodies gang-raped before
killing killed every animal and there
burned the fields and appalling atrocity
appalling in part because the US
government covered it up for a year
appalling because when it finally had to
admit it it handed out to still slap on
the wrists of the commanding officer and
appalling because almost certainly this
was not the only instance of that on the
right is a man named Hugh Thompson this
is the man who stopped the meal i
massacre Thompson was a helicopter pilot
he was piloting a gunship that was
flying over the village and he had
gotten reports of shooting they're
assumed that American troops were under
attack from Viet Cong flew over landed
there to see what help he could give got
out of the helicopter and saw American
troops shooting old women in the head so
American troops pulling babies
underneath from out of their dead
mothers to kill them and this man saw
what was happening and at that point
there was a small surviving number of
villagers huddling at one end of the
village and a group of American soldiers
coming towards them and this man got in
his helicopter and landed it in between
the two and he trained his machine guns
on the American soldiers and said if you
make one more move I will mow you down
in other words over the course of
minutes he had completely changed who
was an us and who is a them and the main
point of all of these people is
none of them have any brain regions that
us that we don't have none of them
invented any new types of
neurotransmitters they do epigenetics
the same way we do the same hormones the
same everything they put their pants on
one leg at a time the same way we do
almost none of them had any indications
beforehand that this was going to be
someone capable of this sort of
extraordinary change so what I think
we're left with here at the end is sort
of an inversion of that like inevitable
santen Jana cliche of those who don't
hunt and study history are destined to
repeat it well we have here I think is
in fact quite the opposite those who
don't study the history of astonishing
human change and don't understand the
science that begins to explain why to
make that more likely those of us who
don't study that are destined not to be
able to repeat moments like these so on
that note thank you for your attention
and good luck with your own best and
worst moments
[Music]
let's see questions well that's pretty
rude well actually that's not rude at
all because you know if I'm trying to be
a good houseguest what I would say is
well if there is some free will you know
it's in increasingly boring places and
you know if you want to claim it was
free will such that you've lost your
lower teeth today instead of your top
ones instead of the other go for it be
happy you know you got free will there
in actuality I don't think it's possible
to look at this whole range of ways in
which our behavior is being shaped by
biology I don't see there to be a shred
of possibility of freewill sitting in
there as far as I'm concerned free will
is what we call the biology that hasn't
been discovered yet I've absolutely no
problem at all with the notion that
there's no free will
I have vast problems with trying to
imagine how are we supposed to live with
that conclusion and I have no idea what
that should look like but all I know is
if we're drunk going to do the hard work
to try to get a sense of where that
should be accepted is we should probably
start with the criminal justice system
and worry about flossing somewhere down
the line there it's an enormous
challenge but there's some domains where
it is absolutely essential that we do it
because basically the science that
informed the current criminal justice
system is based on neuroscience from the
mid 19th century and that's appalling
young
if you happen to know the president of
Stanford can you kind of mention that
but actually I don't know if you paid
your bills okay because very few things
out there have a hundred percent
certainty of you do the work you get the
reward and what we hopefully get very
good at is sensing where the optimum
point is on that curve between effort
and likelihood of reward now what people
are even better at is manipulating us
into distorting what that curve looks
like and that's what Las Vegas is we're
in actuality you have what a hundredth
of one percent of a chance of good but
because today you're the lucky one who
got the free drink and you're on the
penthouse that they put you in that's
actually on the second floor and all of
that and all of that is to set you up to
mistake one chance on a hundred thousand
for at about the 50% mark up goes
dopamine there ago the life savings
we're very good at realizing this early
dopaminergic Lee that intermittent
reward demands a whole lot of behavior
because it's very rewarding we're lousy
at accurately assessing exactly what the
curve looks like
well it depends when my kids are doing
great I don't believe that for a second
context dependency that's the whole
point there Harris is a psychologist who
produced sort of the wildly
controversial book in the mid 90s that
in the most inflammatory form said
parents don't matter
give me a break but she did a very good
critique of a lot of the developmental
literature in terms of parental effects
what she very legitimately emphasized
was how it a surprisingly young age how
strong peer effects are on kids
enormous ly powerful and where that is
never more apparent is in teenagers pure
conformity effects are astonishing there
for example put an adult in a brain
scanner ask somebody okay how do you
think of yourself and they think of it
and there will be a certain pattern of
neural activation now you say how do
other people think of you and there's a
partially overlapping pattern of
cortical and subcortical activation take
a teenager and say what do you think of
yourself what do people think of you you
get the exact same pattern what do I
think of myself whatever anybody else
thinks of me because I'm gonna go along
with whatever thing that's just one
measure of it and that's a measure of
that frontal cortexes job it is in us as
adults to say you know maybe they're
actually jerks and you shouldn't like
take their opinions to heart and that's
all the rationalizing and wait a second
type stuff she's absolutely right
childhood and adolescence even more so
enormous amount of peer effects I I have
a question here okay good I have two
questions actually the first look what
you started okay
is that precedent the first question has
to do with your
discussion of the fear response to the
rattlesnake and later you mentioned that
that fear response is conditioned so I
was wondering if you can talk a little
bit about some of the ways that of the
fear responses are conditioned
particularly with regard to other races
and then the second this is not a
question it's really a point but you
mentioned there were studies where you
know adults had a higher amygdala really
reaction looking at faces that were
different races there than there's
there's another similar study but then
they assess how much contact these
individuals that had with these races
over the course of their life and they
found that that was inversely correlated
so that the more contact they had with
other races the lower the amygdala
response was and vice-versa
good perfect okay so in terms of the
first one rattlesnakes what are these
get your amygdala going things are
innate even the things that are
traditionally viewed as innate phobias
that we have about snakes and spiders
the more technical term is that we show
prepared learning for them we are not
innately afraid of spiders it takes less
aversive okay it takes less it takes
less aversive experience with a spider
to decide that you're afraid of it then
with say like a Teletubby for example we
are predisposed towards making some
associations more readily than others
that's closer to what a phobia actually
is so the question becomes do we have
prepared learning for considering people
of other races to be them's a priori
intuitively that makes perfect sense I
mean it's such a marker and it's
discernible at a distance and all of
that but then you think
anthropologically for a second and race
evolved I don't know 40 50 hundred
thousand years ago or so at most
somewhere during that period and we've
been to monsford on that but most
importantly it only has been okay most
importantly it's only been I know in the
last couple of millennia that your
average person wound up within a
thousand miles of somebody from another
hominid history was not sculpted by
encountering somebody from another race
who represented as much of an other as
you can imagine your whole life he was
utterly irrelevant because somebody's
entire life was spent interacting with
the people from the hunter-gatherer
bands at most 2 or 3 valleys away terms
of that other issue the amygdaloid
response what you get out there is
exactly if one was being boringly
technical and careful every single time
I would have said something during the
talk I would have said on the average
this is what happens on the average
people's amygdala activates when seeing
the face of somebody from another race
so who are the people who are the
exceptions people who grew up in
racially diverse neighborhoods and other
words skin color is not a criterion for
their us to them divide people who have
had a close intimate relationship with
somebody of another race same exact
conclusion okay so good let's put all of
us back into kindergarten and we can
undo some of the world's animosity in
those lines but then wonderful work by
somebody at Princeton named Susan Fiske
has shown something remarkable forget
having to go back to preschool and the
diversity in it
what Fiske does in these studies is
putting somebody in a scanner and you're
flashing up the faces there and the
usual sort of deal and she instructs
people beforehand okay with each face
that you see decide yes or no this
button or that one decide is this the
sort of person who would like broccoli
broccoli like a lot of wars have been
fought over broccoli this is like
totally innocuous broccoli and what are
you doing then you're looking at each
face and you're imagining them in a
market
you're imagining them in a restaurant
you're imagining them coming home and
sitting down to dinner and does this
taste good and is it and in other words
you're imagining them as an individual
and when you individuate people like
that
the amygdala doesn't activate because
you're too busy thinking about if they
look happy you're not biting into
whatever you're thinking about them as a
person and you completely unwire the ask
them at that point so on one hand we
have the option to go back and put
everyone back in kinder
the different sorts of neighborhoods but
in a study like this this is over the
course of seconds you rewire it in other
words I think by the fact that we do us
them stuff and our amygdala in the
course of a hundred milliseconds I think
we are incredibly hard-wired to divide
the world and to us and them and to not
be all the fun all that fond of the
them's but it is incredibly easy to
manipulate us as to who counts us in us
and who counts as of them and put a
baseball cap on somebody in the
neurobiology is different a hundred
milliseconds later and that's the
greatest example of that you can imagine
there's an experiment being conducted to
with transmit transcranial magnetic
induction to suppress the amygdala and
stimulate the frontal lobes do you think
this will work
well depends what working counts as but
one of the most extraordinary things I
mean neuroimaging put somebody in a
brain scanner you're getting functional
MRIs we've seen what parts of the brain
activating different certain it's
totally cool but it's correlative this
part of the brains active activity
correlates with this behavior this
emotional state whatever transcranial
magnetic stimulation is a means by which
you can actually activate or inhibit
small sets of subsets of cortical
neurons and that is amazing some of the
stuff that has come out of that you turn
off a part of the frontal cortex
temporarily in somebody and they make
different sorts of moral decisions you
shift how utilitarian they are and
runaway trolley type problems and you
are controlling their behavior in that
case this is mostly just a phenomenal
research tool because you're moving away
from a correlative relationship to a
causal one
AHA make those neurons fire and suddenly
this person is far more likely to say
yeah I push them in front of the trolley
that's a strong causal relationship what
you can actually do with that down the
line is the stuff of dreams and
nightmares and everything in between my
guess is it's not going to be used in
terribly exciting abusive ways anytime
soon but
a phenomenal research tool
[Applause]
[Music]